we have a game we're about to play all
right this is called the last chance
game get it did you like penis here's
how it works we each take turns pressing
this button that looks like it's not
connected to anything but I promise you
it's on some kind of cool Bluetooth or
wireless thingy or something like that
it's great when we press it when we
press the last chance generator that's
what we call it the last chance
generator it will generate a question
about the last time you did something so
we each have to answer though although
we all get one press we all have to
answer the question and if you don't
want to answer the question that's fine
you're scared and we get it you can
dance
my bando plain you could dance if you
don't want to answer it okay chance you
said you like to dance and you're from
Vegas you've got this okay
all right chance you'll go first go
ahead press that button or the generator
[Music]
last dream you had that you remember I
remember a dream I was or a nightmare I
was running away and I couldn't I
couldn't get to wherever I was trying to
get I'm sorry I'm trying to make you
guys my therapist right now I'm trying
to figure out what this means that
there's a Joseph in the crowd yeah no I
couldn't get that so that's my that's my
dream you didn't get there what we need
a dream book oh yeah that's what that
means to have one of those I have 100
years but it was always just like you're
dying running away like the last dream
you know mine was that I was doing a
live show and I wasn't prepared for it I
get that a lot
I have this reoccurring dream and I
haven't had him forever and I was just
telling someone recently actually that I
had this dream it the house is on fire
and there's a boy yelling for help and
then I try and find him in the houses on
fire and I find him and he's older than
me and then I reach for him and when he
touches my hand the dream is over it's
happened since I was a kid what does
that mean it's so cinematic well you
need to shoot a baby it's a short film
so it's my turn I'm gonna go I think we
just skipped you okay okay last time
last time you passed gas and blamed it
on someone else um here's the thing
about me
the whole thing no filters true colors
that's true I will own it I'll be like
I'm sorry but I'm not taking that pain
for anyone yeah so I don't ever blame it
on anyone I kind of do the same as you I
will walk to the other side of the room
and everyone's like what's happening and
I go something it's a Bruin dumb things
happening I die always blame it on
someone else especially a face
especially if it's just me and one other
person like in a small room I'll be like
what oh my god it's like it's me one
other person may know it's you that's a
part of it though do they know
themselves that well you're throwing
them I think that means you're old you
don't realize you far
I love you chance oh my gosh oh wait
you're sitting work yeah we didn't work
this is the dream you're feeling okay
last person you met who truly impressed
you I mean I'm Nick and Kelly I already
knew Kelly the last person it was only
because he saved the day like our very
first person we were supposed have on
the show was Kevin Hart and he got in
that accident and so literally down to
the minute we had nolan and dwayne
johnson cancelled and he didn't cancel
he left us on him in a day early and
came to my show for me so really
impressed we know each other
his wife is still there no one told her
i think the reason why he came on that
night very thankful for her anyway that
was a really fun game today if you smell
gas from your near chance he did it and
we didn't get a chance to dance so let's
dance to the break we'll be back y'all I
[Applause]
[Music]
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this